[Music]
greetings humans uh
it has been brought to my attention that
many of you have been going to build.com
and entering in the promo code crowder15
for 15 off and uh given sending build
bars to the studios
this is a miscommunication
because build bars are not good for dogs
yes they uh
are
keto friendly with uh the low carbs and
they have close to 20 grams of protein
but they also have real
belgian dark chocolate which as you know
are
are bad for dogs
and
this is why i would request that you not
go to built.com
but instead
send garbage
garbage is part of a balanced and
fortified diet for all joe lewis's and
dogs
it has everything
that a dog needs and does the body good
and it is much better for uh
than a build bar
so
no more build bars
even if you think you're delicious don't
be selfish
please just send garbage
[Music]
june 18th pikes peak center colorado
springs colorado prepares
for the funniest show
on
earth
the clock is completely wrong in your
car it says it's 108.
it's right to me
it's two
it's 227 yeah but it's 108 to me
because i set it back for
uh kwanzaa
that doesn't even make any that doesn't
daylight kwanzaa
savings
there's no i just don't this is this is
an entirely useless everything about
this clock is wrong it's an entirely
useless clock it's easter
easter easter time just now you're just
naming holidays
thanksgiving
shabbos
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
hey why don't you guys ever tell me i
realize you never tell me to like fix my
hair before i go on air i don't know
what fix your hair looks like that's
true just run your fingers through it
and i'm like oh it looks like a lady's
been running her fingers through my hair
not a ladies an old lady oh yeah an old
lady never tell the story about that
time that uh by hel by the way hello
we'll be talking about hey i don't know
if you can see that that's the third
rail the great replacement theory ah
we'll be talking about that today so my
question to you before anything else is
um
what do you think the great replacement
theory is
how do you think the leftist media is
portraying it and is there some truth to
it and can there be truth to it without
it being racist and i'm using the term
the great replacement therapy because
that because that's what they're coining
it but i'm going to be clear it's not
it's not about race it's not about even
culture it's about voting demographics
so let's be clear about that we don't
need to load it
with race
there's an issue and it's an issue of
buying votes so we're going to touch
that today and
you know look if we get banned here on
youtube if we do not tell you that we
are not doing a show
that means that we are still live
streaming rumble
rumble right now in mug club today's
chat thursday an extra 45 minutes of
show i want to be done by 10.50 today
because we're supposed to be done by
1045 but we never actually make it
that's true we don't do it and uh
nothing would make me happier than for
as many people from youtube right now to
just go over to rumble go over to mud
club
you guys often complain about like why
are you still on youtube well you can
not be
it's your fault so a seagull pooped on
my head dave and uh
yes old port montreal and i used to have
people thought my mom frosted my hair
which would be child abuse
yes it would be she's just giving me
some estrogen injections i thought it
was frosty tipped yes yes she thought
they thought i was a member of 98
degrees yes you were in a boyfriend
and this old lady at first she goes oh
yeah
she which means oh night and she went
and she
touched my hair and got seagull crap all
over her hand oh so that's how she died
yeah yeah well she looked her you don't
have to lick your fingers
too many kernel commercials it's a
finger like if someone took that too
literally and they ended up with no
fingers in them
all right look i've been pooped down by
a bird many times yeah well you're very
lucky guy yeah liberal bird as you know
i walk around with a parrot when i'm not
on camera yes you're jack sparrow yeah
like well
i prefer to be called well it's like
dude he prefers to be called
geese she poops she poops oh my gosh i
remember her did you watch amber yes
okay anyway so we have a lot to talk
about we're going to be talking about
the great replacement theory and how the
left is portraying it i think this is
something that needs to be addressed and
unfortunately you have people uh
people in hysterics on both sides by the
way the great replacement theory started
with and was presented as a virtue by
the left and you don't have to take my
word for it we have all references
available today at lotterycredit.com uh
and uh some history and immigration laws
and i don't know if you know who screwed
it up uh professional uh professional
driver ted kennedy ah yes
king of the oldsmobile yes the first
uber yes yep
to get it to get a one star review baby
you can hide my car
all right
yeah as you script or drive dead kennedy
uh with the dead kennedy with uh ted
kennedy if you like the second
underwater level of super mario all
right let's go to gerald how are you i
am well sir how are you
i'm okay yesterday oh my gosh it was so
you guys may not notice but yesterday i
was doing this a lot because i thought
you were just like i was doing it again
this year's catalog family portrait
but it was just kind of they couldn't
support my own neck
oh gosh what are you like the giraffe
with a bracelet yes jeffrey jeffrey step
up with jeffrey and then
my bathroom do you no but i should yeah
you should sometimes i can't get the
sink
[Music]
why are you peeing in the sink you hear
him you know him you love him he's
available
dave and he and i will be in colorado
springs june 18th we added a second show
it's it's early because of how the venue
works i think it's like at 3 30. so
there are some tickets left not many
we're letting you know right now because
there are a lot of walk-ins and then
they just won't be available so that's
our last show here
boy i'm sorry no no you're fine how are
you i don't know i just fell out of my
mouth while you were talking ahoy
i i don't know q's cues
johnny depp makes a really good really
good gay pirate he does i actually
realize is jack sparrow gay
yeah he just act everything every
character johnny depp does is kind of
gay i realize though jack sparrow it's
not that i thought it was really more of
a character it's not it's just john yet
when he's drunk when he listens to the
tape really is it's keith richards yeah
i know but it's johnny depp when he's
drunk as well yes he listens to the
tapes he sounds like jack sparrow he's
talking to amber hurt listen you you
threw you through the door and you
punched me
don't tell me what it's like to be
punched stop running your lines
hey can you come in and read for this
yes but i'm drunk that works perfectly
that works perfectly get them the
earpiece will be gold
before all that we're gonna hit some
heavy stuff here today it's time to
watch and react now you've heard about
the uh shoplifters all over the country
mm-hmm
most of them are irish
and
what here's one that just happened
recently this is another muslim yes
yes those those near duels yes
good thing we can take care of them with
a good old cop on his beat with his
billy club potato eaters you mean the
irish that take care of the irish yes
exactly
we're going to take out her own trash
so this happened at best buy and this is
another reason why um you know uh some
jobs are not well suited
to women
[Music]
here comes the robber
[Music]
she tried to get in the way did i say
women i'm sorry that was about what i
meant to say was white women because who
can forget this
keep your feet moving
move hands
well yeah yeah
that was that a woman well it was moana
grown up oh that's what i thought oh wow
she just stopped she was just like an
old lineman like no no no it was
impressive that was really good
good for her good for her honestly i
would love to have her on the show yeah
you're racist no i love to see a black
woman beat up a a criminal i don't care
who's beating up the criminal i do no
especially if it's a black woman just
because it's funny cause it's a woman
yeah and she's beating you up yep that's
well deserved
[Laughter]
it's a good bouncer to have yeah it's
like all right she'll throw you out yes
what happened i got thrown at buffalo
wild wings by a lady love how she threw
him through the sign yeah she just kept
going and committed like i've stopped
you no you're going through this yeah
she's like it's a close-out sale mother
that's right he's like oh wow that is
he's right he's going down he's like 30
off that is a good deal uncle i think i
pooped myself
oh by the way we need to administer no
no admonish gerald no because that
marine story yesterday on the porch no
turns out admonish him
it turns out it wasn't real it was
staged
really that's what people are saying i
will say this we have never actually
gotten a new story wrong the only
thing's ever gotten wrong is where it's
a clip that we think is really funny
it's still really funny still and you
know what it's worth it good performance
guys it was cathartic oh it was still
one of the funniest things i've ever
seen in my life now i told you guys
about that clip i couldn't find the
video though
that was the whole thing somebody else
independent from me put it in there on
their own
yeah gerald made the calls yeah the call
i did not make the call at all i didn't
even promote it to anybody someone get
jocko willink on the line extreme
ownership yes somebody needs to own that
they put that in there and it wasn't me
oh he hasn't read the book okay
[Laughter]
it won't take you very long
i'll read it slide it under the door yes
um 408 my bad
so here here's something else again that
is affecting you right and we'll talk
about the great replacement therapy
therapy theory admonish after you
[Laughter]
just know
look the admonish is not to be used
sorry that way
no you don't use it really nearly rule
is take responsibility you need to
respect the admonish button
like magnolia respect
he admonished now
dave's the only one who knows the one
word change in that line yes
so uh not a good film gas prices though
before we get to the great replacement
this is affecting reigning frogs
sorry this no one cares about me yeah
that's a horrible film i just did i i
didn't think it was horrible but then
that happens and you're like well this
is enough yes
ah i think i can just go to bed early
yeah oh good great so gas prices around
the country here they're they're
skyrocketing and i believe what we have
is a clip from cnn this morning right so
this is something i was watching cnn
this morning and i and by watching i
mean it was playing on my phone through
a speaker in the shower i have no time
for myself in the morning
and i was getting mad in the shower
because this just shows the disconnect
again the disconnect between you and
those in media so they acknowledge that
we have record high gas prices
now
that should be we have record high gas
prices yeah and you
should not be blamed for it
but cnn decides to come up with a
solution and this it is as bad as it
gets this was just this morning a couple
hours ago
the next looming crisis fuel shortages
this is diesel prices skyrocket diesel
right now at a record 5.58 a gallon
today and key tanks like these that
you're seeing in new york harbor those
tanks supply the northeast and they're
running dry but the consumer holds some
power to turn the tide of high prices
our relentless buying and spending
inflicted on a brittle supply chain are
contributing to the high price of diesel
flickers and at some point the
consumer's gonna say all right enough's
enough i gotta i gotta slow down this is
taking too much of my disposable income
if we do have a pullback
stupid economy all your disposable
income
it gets worse you just mentioned one
more time that the consumer you and i
and people at home do hold a lot of
power to potentially lowering prices if
we decide to stop spending more on goods
and services that will bring down
presumably the price of diesel because
we won't need as many ships as many
trains and planes to get goods to our
front door
what she just described is a recession
hey consumers
if you stop making the economy go around
stop putting gas in your car stop buying
food and i don't know formula things you
need to eat and then guess what then we
can unemploy the people who run shipping
companies and who who run trains this is
their solution is literally i hate to
say this but when people talk about a
crash the great reset being orchestrated
you combine this with leftists like vox
saying that you shouldn't be
breastfeeding even with a formula
shortage yeah you go well how can you
guys be wrong on everything and not only
wrong but advocating for people to act
wrongly i don't know about running
trains i think the porn industry is
doing pretty well that's true
we can stephen basically worth as a
bubble we can get rid of cancer if we
just kill the patient
that's absolutely the solution that she
just proposed and by the way i don't
give a medicine i just want you to
understand that diesel prices will not
be affected affected by planes because
they run on jet fuel not diesel well
there are some planes that run on diesel
diamonds that's not true the diamonds
like there no that's and that's actually
something that's a good example there
have been very little advancements in
personal aviation because of the
unbelievable faa restrictions we should
be advancing you can have they put
mercedes engines in planes that are
diesel engines and these are some of the
most reliable personal planes right now
there should be a boom in personal
aviation how do you think that you have
to have a learjet no i'm talking about
getting an affordable plane where you
can pop in two people or four people
suvs of the sky there are a few options
out there but they're incredibly
expensive because it takes like two
decades to bring to market yeah so you
know what you can buy an experimental
aircraft so there are two separate
markets right now but right now
ticket prices for i just paid two
thousand dollars for a flight to see my
aunt i may not be that much maybe like a
thousand four hundred well it's close
enough that shouldn't be that one no
it's like a grand i fly to detroit dude
it's nuts man absolutely it's like 600
bucks if you want to upgrade you're like
i'm sorry what well the good news is if
you stop purchasing plane tickets and no
longer see your family then uh of course
american airlines can go under and then
we can bail them out so back to you john
very cool we can print money yeah
and then your dollar is worth less yes
by the way here's before we get to some
of this with the gas prices and what's
happening
here they're really just two questions
you need to ask yourself and we'll have
all the references available but when
you speak with other people about this
and they try and present well actually
it's international and it's russia and
okay let's assu let's assume that that's
a factor okay
are there actions that we could be
taking here in the united states
to increase our energy capacity here in
this country meaning let's shut out the
rest of the world are there actions that
we could take here in the united states
the answer is unequivocally yes are we
doing that no we're doing the opposite
of that yeah first day in office and he
was proud to do it keystone bye-bye
nordstrom 2 hey welcome to the just ask
yourself those two questions and then
you can get to the y
but yesterday gas prices nationwide okay
they broke records they were talking
about diesel but ninth day
in a row at a certain point stop
measuring stop saying it's a record it's
like phelps yeah i think he comes out to
you know like chat you're like hey guys
now the record yeah it's like mcdonald's
it's like stop changing the number on
the sign we get it you're doing you're
doing good you've killed now yeah i
understand now do deaths yes yeah
so gasps two arteries 16 cents in a week
48 cents in a month
buck 52 in the last year the average in
the country right now is 458 per gallon
according to aaa regular unleaded gas in
california is six dollars and six cents
but they have a surplus said gavin
newsom yeah yeah when you tax and you
overcharge and then people are leaving
so you don't have to spend money on them
yeah when you steal from your citizens
of course you have a surplus of course
yeah so did the royalty before robin
hood got to work
[Laughter]
this is just it's one of those issues
well you can just stop driving yeah or
you can just stop purchasing you're
being very selfish getting behind the
wheel of your own car you're filling it
with gas that's nineteen dollars a gap
yes well and we're heading into summer
when this is just gonna get worse
there's a formula shortage shut that
baby up yeah why is it crying yeah why
is it so needy why are you raising such
a little [ __ ] no no don't use your
breasts no
no then you'll lose your bottle you'll
lose your bodily autonomy said vox
that's an actual thing we almost ran
seriously yes yes i really listed the
negative ramifications of breastfeeding
and i'm going by rote but i'm pretty
sure someone that can bring up the
graphic it said fatigue yeah inability
to work
anxiety loss of bodily autonomy that's
what they're for
it's the only thing they're for and fun
but primarily
wow yeah the many many costs now and
then they had a picture of a ladies
gross nipples yes why are you feeding
your baby what do you want to look like
a [ __ ] from a puppy mill ah gross buy
some similac you [ __ ] those are for
slapping not for feeding oh it's it's
really bad yeah there's another one
where there's a picture of a lady and
she's like oh i'm losing my bodily
autonomy oh yeah everyone's gonna think
i'm gross
you're losing your bodily autonomy by
feeding your children this is the
dumbest thing i've ever seen they say
don't breastfeed okay
just don't drive okay
just don't purchase goods and services
with your money that you've worked for
which is worth less now because we're in
rental we're creating
just burn your money and that will
supply will go down and the dollar will
be more valuable the only problem is
that's highly illegal oh legal tender
and what have you can't burn money yeah
look right here what does it say it says
judgment so this is this is the
emotional health trauma keep this up for
me it looks like it's ebony greeting
card yes yes
no no keep it up give it up just keep it
up keep it i told you give it up just
because dave made me left don't take it
down
this is the toll on the emotional health
judgment from strangers
significant loss of time
exhaustion ah loss of bodily autonomy
why would you put this out to people
this is how they view babies folks that
baby's trying to make that baby's trying
to make you exhausted and drain you of
your bodily autonomy you had it yeah
well look you do get exhausted yes but
that's part of it my wife is
breastfeeding right now it is work to do
it but it is incredibly rewarding to be
able to do that if you can for your
child she is breastfeeding by the way
gerald save some for the baby
honey i know you're watching right now i
apologize for stephen uh did i clean my
milk mustache uh well you know what just
keep it we're gonna do a commercial
dave's not invited to dinner anymore
either which is always an odd commercial
to me like who's spending money on milk
campaigns i thought we were allowed to
choose what meal we wanted yeah it's not
a buffet well there's the choice is it's
different it's like you have a choice
for normal vegan and then kosher it's
not just you can't just sexually assault
normal vegan
so gas prices are at an all-time high
this affects all of you and we actually
have a uh
to show what's going on here in our in
our locale we actually sent on the
ground of course are on the ground
getting the scoop uh correspondent
thomas finnegan to uh gas stations to
see
what is happening let's go
[Music]
mr finnegan okay
can you tell us what's happening
i'm here outside a local gas station
right slow down on why the prices are so
high around the country as you can see
439 a gallon is hardly a bargain no
uh
i don't advise you shouldn't be uh
finnegan is this your piece even working
fit again
finnegan can you hear me can we not do
the cigarettes bad idea finnegan
finnegan
sign clear yeah uh yeah so this is our
reasons why
prices could be so high
one of them is that it's just apparently
not gas season
vegetables are more expensive in the
winter time so is gas at specific times
of the year another factor is elon musk
is sending spaceships to outer space
and those spaceships take a lot of gas
and they don't run off of batteries
that's not the factor we're going to try
our due diligence and check out one more
location
to make sure that
we have all the information possible
we've given no information thus far
[Music]
well we'll check back in with him but my
i don't have high hopes now at least
he's consistent i asked him if he quit
smoking and he said i quit quitting and
spit on my shoe
yeah i've been in a mood it's a touchy
topic for him yeah the alimony is not
easy no he's not happy about it poor guy
he has to pay alimony on what he doesn't
make i know i pay him
really weird so hey you guys remember
the department of misinformation the
ministry of truth yeah but we talked
about this yesterday but it is uh
officially dead yes
so that's good
i know you take the wins where you can
get them yeah of course
uh and they have said that it has been
paused indefinitely which means dead
which bye-bye so with the paws remember
nina jankowicz yeah she was the uh she
was the worst
uh she decided to step down she told cbs
with the board's work paused and its
future uncertain i have decided to leave
dhs to return to my work in the public
sphere okay you're so fired you didn't
step down
no no i left it was me it's like it's
like when sears closed down and the
ceo's like i think i'm going to quit yes
there is no sears you can't fire me i
quit
why don't i fit in
it is deeply disappointing that
mischaracterizations of the board became
a distraction from the department's
vital work and indeed along with recent
events globally and nationally embodies
why it is necessary i love how basically
they said all right let's just get rid
of this because it's not necessary she's
like that's why it's most necessary
they said we're gonna get rid of this
because it's a terrible idea and
everybody saw that it was a terrible
idea well like amber heard and people
like her not all women just a
significant portion of them particularly
in the entertainment industry with
histrionic personality disorder uh the
left is claiming that jankowitz was the
victim of coordinated online attacks
this is at washington post by taylor
laurent she wrote jankowitz has been
subject to an unrelenting barrage of
harassment and abuse while unchecked
misrepresentations of her work continue
to go viral keep in mind this is taylor
loren's running interference for this uh
crazy radical feminist pro-censorship
leftist advocate right so
she's she's the one running the
department of misinformation and then
you have taylor lorenz who by the way
docks the libs of tick tocks in case
case you forget this is her at their
house
and she's talking about
mischaracterizations and abuse
oh i guess there isn't a chapter on
quitting and going home when things get
hard i guess no no no she just write
books about that she doesn't write books
about that no i'm sorry and by the way
in case you wanted to uh book you wore a
mask in case you wanted to book this uh
this um
batshit harpy for an engagement in the
future
she has some conditions this is uh this
is jankowitz she wrote
and by the way i'm going to read this
exactly as she wrote it can you define
it and dave you're going to see why
all right as a comedian you'll
appreciate
the lack of appreciation she has so she
says a note on mantles i will not
participate as a moderator of an
all-male panel or mantle okay
[Laughter]
she leads with mantles
to act as though we all know but then
she immediately concedes that you don't
know it's a thing i'm trying to make a
thing stop trying to make mantle or
fetch a thing well if you're if you're
on it it's not a mantle no you'd be the
factor yeah exactly it'd be the third
whale yeah she's like don't include me
in those i don't want to be on a one
mole yeah no hey wish granted not
included right
no problem you weren't invited yeah
well i didn't want to go anyway i quit
yeah i'm done i'm done i don't want to
be part of your stupid mantel anyway i'm
going to go start my own panel
that one was dissolved too damn i can't
catch a break yeah you like to go to a
lot of places you aren't invited to
so a note on mantles i will not
participate as a moderator of an all
male panel or mantle and i will
seriously reconsider my participation if
your organization has any manuals on its
agenda for the event in question then
she went on to say
this is her by the way it's like this is
not a good job application no
this is not something that you should
put on your linkedin well unless you're
applying to be a [ __ ] yes well then
you're tired
i like the cut of your jib we pay very
little and we harass quite a bit yes
welcome how's 79 cents sound to you if
you need it
if you need references for women experts
please ask or better yet consult the
websites
consult these websites women also know
stuff interrupted she source or google
which should tell you everything you
need to know about google that it's
right alongside women interrupted and
she sores well it's all women know stuff
also no stuff i'm like wait a minute
that's gerald and those stuffs they they
stepped on my stuff that's my name yeah
yes that's terrible and i love how
they're conceiving
ground of women also know stuff
why don't you call it women know stuff
well because men know more stuff but we
know things also
yeah you're kind of putting yourself
down yeah exactly
interrupted oh my gosh well maybe it's
because you'd go on too long yeah
victim complex yeah yeah you know what
maybe you're not interrupted maybe it's
just that you never shut up yeah i think
that's maybe it i'm so glad this person
is not in charge of truth anymore
i i appreciate that you used a
gender-neutral description this person
person i didn't want to say something
ugly i don't know the pronouns for [ __ ]
and i'm glad you pointed out what she
doesn't do truth yes well that's yes but
her truth which is a lie or any man with
self-respect yes she doesn't do that
either no she does not yeah the tick
tucker yeah exactly yeah that's gotta be
you have to be into like bondage or sm
or humiliation to date someone like that
right like
like let's go out to dinner and you can
just put me down in front of the waist
exactly
just dress me down in front of my family
yeah order for me
no all male spaces okay i will not be
the only woman to break the barrier
he'll have the cosmopolitan i don't want
that he'll have the cosmopolitan okay oh
yes i will all right
she's like friends with jada did you so
it's okay did you just pull my chair out
for me
just breaks his hand
when she walks in the room will smith
slap somebody yes exactly oh yeah she
definitely i guarantee you she has those
pinkett eyes this is one of the and by
the way the concern here is they're just
going to do this in private they thought
this shows the disconnect again they
thought they would announce look we have
a radical feminist and a department of
misinformation and they were expecting
like
and instead everyone said what and they
said never mind so they're just going to
do it privately because they realize
that they need to push their agenda uh
in an underhanded way as it relates to
the american people specifically with
latinos and black americans democrats
are going to lose them the second that
these demographics find out what they
actually want when you look on the
individual issues it's not even close so
by the way we were this close think
about it this close
to having a radical
man-hating feminist
determine what is true and false
on all of social media in all of america
thank god we dodged that [ __ ] it but
think about how close we were to it
so nina jankowitz
thank you it's time for her time to
close
in april the department of homeland
security announced the creation of a
disinformation governance board now the
woman appointed to lead that effort is a
woman named nina jenkowitz she's a
former disinformation fellow at the
wilson center and the author of the book
how to lose the information war i want
to be rich
famous and powerful
[Music]
president biden's disinformation czar
quit today
[Music]
barely later in 2022. i have never had
douche chills quite like that with her
singing
she's the timothy dalton of
misinformation
[Laughter]
good thing yeah model yourself after a
dishonest ethel merman yes
[Laughter]
i want to be like ethel merman but lie a
lot this is terrible say no more i've
come to the right place we've started a
branch of government for you
and in two weeks that branch is going to
fall so you're kind of going out on a
limb and we don't care yeah you did the
exact job we thought you would do hey
they lasted longer than cnn plus i think
that is true
that is true
so at least you know nina jankowicz you
have brian stelter's jealousy and no one
can ever take that from you
which by the way is jealous over your
handbag as well yes
no one can ever take from me my built
bars if you go to built.com and use a
promo code crowder15 you get 15 off your
next order don't listen to joe lewis in
the intro do not send trash that's a
problem that we're trying to get him to
stop doing
and i don't feed him built bars anyway
so i don't know what he's complaining
about because it's real chocolate these
things are delicious i use them just as
dessert this is the birthday cake box
because we've run out of all the other
boxes yeah i don't like birthday cake
okay i just don't like birthday cake
period i got sick on it one year so i
can't eat anything it tastes like
birthday cake but people who like
birthday cake love this stuff i love the
chocolate ones the peanut butter oh yeah
yeah the yeah the fudge brownie but a
huge fan of candles
no those are terrible too but depends on
how they're scented i'd light them and
leave them in your place and then you
throw up when you walk in the door it's
true yeah kind of fun for me yeah but uh
bill you know they're sponsored because
i actually use their stuff no one needs
protein bars one thing you think you can
take it and get jacked but it's a good
way to replace desserts and have
something that just actually tastes good
you work out with those yeah i do yeah
oh i thought you just eat them
[Applause]
but this is the thing there's so many
people all over instagram like you know
you want to know how you want to know
how i got big it's like yeah uh
tyriniball uh it's because i took this t
and it's like okay the rock
that's natural at 50. yeah sure you just
keep getting bigger and bigger totally
like all people that age and your
forehead raised three inches like a
three stooges sketch yeah you and mark
maguire he's got so much juice in him
and doesn't know where to go it's just
creating body parts yes
he has a tattoo that reads the rock made
from concentrated
[Laughter]
so
here's something that we should talk
about too before we get to the great
replacement therapy because it's a
therapy why am i saying therapy i don't
know the great
[Laughter]
back to you that's the perfect answer i
haven't i have no idea they don't call
him the best color guy in the business
for no reason yes exactly
you're like the dennis miller of the nfl
i bet you had trt on the mind because
we're talking about all the roads oh
yeah it's probably we're talking about
therapy yeah yeah although really that's
not steroids old guys should be taking
that stuff in her thigh therapy yes yes
that's what i do yeah well that's the
thigh master therapy yes i need to
update your training methods i have but
i bought so many he has so many thigh
masters and buns of steel vhs tapes i
literally don't have furniture
he just sits on stacks of videos
of the health writer dave so
there was a shooting that happened last
week and everyone's been talking
obviously about uh i was about to say
milwaukee because but no they're not
talking about milwaukee it's about
buffalo so there was dallas there was
orange county there were milwaukee
these were the worst shootings and
they're only discussing buffalo yeah
okay there was another shooting last
week though that is getting almost no
national coverage
and i wanted to bring it to your
attention
uh because for the life of me i can't
figure out why
i may have an idea
police say the black suspect who shot
three women at a korean hair salon was
angry at all asians because of a bad
experience during a traffic accident
with an asian driver hello everybody i'm
steve eager it's nine o'clock an arrest
warrant affidavit for 37 year old jeremy
smith says that that was the reason for
his hatred of asians was relayed to
police by his girlfriend she also told
them smith was once fired for attacking
an asian boss he was arrested while
working a temporary landscaping job and
charged with three counts of aggravated
assault with a deadly weapon in addition
to the salon shooting police are looking
at whether he shot at two other
asian-owned businesses
well i'm noticing a theme
and this was not covered that was local
media right you would think it get
national coverage no no no no no it's
just local who could have possibly
predicted such a strange turn of events
as far as the identity of this shooting
if only someone hmm
they just announced that they've made an
arrest in the dallas shooting of a
korean-owned
hair salon cnn just covered the entire
story i didn't hear any mention of race
but it was a korean-owned salon and i'm
just curious if the race is known so you
guys look it up and see if the rest just
happened there was a shooting in a
korean salon uh it happened a couple of
days ago
i don't know how many people remember
when one happened i don't remember if i
was in texas the guy shut up the massage
parlor and that was racially emotional
that was but it was because in georgia
or something yeah yeah
they didn't want to give him handies
[Laughter]
he went to the wrong song for that it's
like yeah you gotta go to the right
place
this was from an hour ago but the dallas
morning news says that the police
announced the arrest early tuesday but
did not provide the suspect's name so i
don't think we're going to get the race
okay yeah
all right yeah well i'm just curious one
guess
weird
i tell you that zoltar machine in the
green room is the best investment we
ever really is thing ever i still only
grew partway to big yeah and by the way
if you think that they didn't know who
this person was from the outset you're
wrong they had this story when that
story ran on the 17th they had this
information but it was then remembered
and by the way just like if you have to
pay for gas at the pump it's your fault
you should stop purchasing gas if you
notice the statistical trend in crime in
this country particularly uh as it's a
perpetuate against asians
you're wrong you shouldn't be doing that
and that's where we're going to discuss
the great replacement theory next but
let's uh it this so this was last week
the guy was 37 year old jeremy smith
it was at harold salon in dallas texas
shot three women yeah
luckily think i mean thank god none of
them were killed uh it is being
investigated i mean i don't know hate
crimes another
because it can be racist from a black
person to another well
as far as motive because sometimes you
don't you don't want to just here's the
thing just because a white guy shoots
somebody it's not because right he
happens to be white and just because a
black guy shoots somebody it doesn't
necessarily mean it's because he's black
or because the victim is white or the
victim is asian that doesn't determine
motive in this case though the
girlfriend did say anytime the suspect
smith is around anyone of asian descent
he begins having delusions that the
asian mob is after him or attempting to
harm him so that seems pretty clear
that's weird i i don't know why you
would uh date him yeah why would the
yakuza be coming after you mister what
are you counting cards well perhaps he
owes money to someone well that may be
true maybe it's very legitimate but how
did what did he travel to japan just to
screw with the yakuza to come back i
mean it's a pretty insular world but why
would you like
you're asian you're like what are you
like well
long walks on the beach i like to watch
movies i also uh freak out every time i
see an asian person yeah yes oh yeah
let's go let's go to a korean salon i go
into an epileptic seizure and wake up
later and i just they're dead yeah i
don't know what it is like oh well you
know what it sounds like it's a sound
like it's a man who's a fixer-upper
as long as you've never been on a mantel
yeah he's a bad boy i like men that i
can fix i love that you're so old he's a
fixer-upper oh he's got a gun up now i
know i've made some bad decisions
so let's uh let's sort of compare then
remember what our former vice president
said after the atlanta spa shooting last
year the salon shooting that we just
discussed there are simply some core
values and beliefs that should bring us
together as americans one of them
is standing together against hate
against racism
the ugly poison that has long haunted
and plagued our nation now i want to be
clear again that wasn't racially
motivated it was just a guy who was mad
because he was a sex fiend yeah but they
immediately went through the racial
motivation for a white guy who shot i
believe three people well you know he
may have shot five people or something
just he shot enough he shot enough
immediately they went to race right
immediately immediately now they
excluded it from the conversation but
here's the thing here's how former vice
president biden uh addressed when we
basically have an anti-asian manifesto
and uh of with the kind of insanities
that you would only see from someone
with serious psychiatric disorders and
also racist so let's see how former vice
president biden addressed the shooting
where we know the motive in dallas
that's very similar to how he addressed
all the asians getting killed in new
york city you mean they didn't want to
be shoved in front of the l train i
guess i just thought it was a thing why
would you stand that close to it i just
thought they were adrenaline junkies
no so bad awful
so here's also by the way uh gingersnap
was here just to give you a little bit
of insight uh uh he went he went over
there to the salon and uh he noticed one
thing the salon where they shot bring up
those images
you know no guns allowed
no guns did he not see the sign i don't
know apparently the force field lapsed
that's crazy maybe he's illiterate
well maybe just pete wait hold on people
and he just shot asian women well it
wasn't because of anything other than he
just obviously didn't pay attention to
the sign or he can't read he could
possibly not read well he may not have
understood what the the ghostbuster gun
thing yeah meant
who else we don't know fair point he may
not be able to read we don't know if he
drove miss daisy well if he can't read
then he's probably going to be uh not
fit to stand trial oh
yeah likely yeah some other examples
is he out yet on no bail
uh the man who beat the old man in
detroit no no he's he's free to go yeah
he's free to go yeah he's on the streets
yes exactly yeah right where the lord
wants him yes
point him to the old folks home yep he's
got some mercy to give might i suggest
bob evans at the early bird hour yes
enjoy
so all you can punch buffet yes
that's just golden corral
so uh if there's one steak left yeah
ginger
it's not even sirloin ginger snap
actually asked business owners in the
neighborhood about this and none of the
business owners had guns and most of the
korean business owners they found gun
scary and they said that the police
would help so this is just anecdotal i'm
letting you know there were discussions
that were taking place yeah here's the
thing look asian americans
right now and just to be clear i know
people say how can you speak i'm not
speaking for you i'm not asian american
i am speaking to you i'm speaking with
you you know who else is an asian
american former vice president biden i
guess kamala is when she chooses that
it's convenient but come on you ain't
black let's be honest
[Laughter]
but democrats don't give a crap about
you
they use you remember when a stop asian
hate what happened with that once the
statistics came out they don't care hey
where are the democrats fighting against
the quotas that you're seeing at
universities right now there's you know
happen in harvard and brown where they
say no we have too many asians where are
they right now i'm telling you i do i
care and by the way i don't just say you
know asian americans before you start
feeling super special i don't care about
you any more than i care about any other
form of american white american black
american i'm just saying that i want you
to have the same rights and fighting
chance i want you to arm yourselves i
want you to be able to protect your
businesses i encourage you to protect
your businesses and i encourage you to
go to states that allow you to protect
your homes and businesses because as you
see the police cannot save you yeah i
want somebody like mr smith to be
terrified that somebody is going to
shoot him as he walks in with the gun in
his hand trying to shoot them i want
somebody to go
i don't know if i can go in there
because these guys might have a gun as
well instead of going ah there's no way
they got a sign on the door that says no
guns perfect what do you think would
stop a shooter like you more effectively
the sign that says no guns or a turret
well i'm gonna say what if it's a turret
of signs well it could be all well
uh also let me update you too on
milwaukee another thing that the another
i want to say thing because i it's not
one shooting
it was several shootings right there are
three suspects who were arrested
connection there was a shooting that
injured
16 people
and there were other i believe it was
over 20 when you add them all up yeah
there was an earlier shooting i believe
to that one uh that happened probably a
few hours or so before on that same
night yeah and of course look the reason
the media isn't really covering it so
much is the same reason they don't cover
chicago and i understand it's not the
same as someone running in shooting up a
school gang related but guess what a lot
of kids get tripped up in gang-related
activity not only in actual shootings in
bad areas of town where often black
people have to live
and i'm saying that because you say that
you say it when you talk about climate
justice yes many black americans live in
poorer areas where there is more
significant crime kids get caught on
crossfire all the time not to mention
kids get recruited at a young age in
these areas so gang crime is relevant
and that is why when you look at mass
shootings it's not
the angry white guy who commits the vast
majority of them people are just wrong
about that these statistics matter hey
asians
statistically you're most likely very
very likely to be violently assaulted by
a black person hey black americans
statistically you are most likely to be
shot and killed not by a white guy not
by a cop by another black person
now empathy is not ignoring that fact
that's what i really don't like about it
i know
i know it just makes zero sense well in
focusing every bit of your effort on
these tragedies which deserve focus yes
absolutely focusing no energy on hey
chicago you guys had 15 to 20 people
killed again this weekend right again
this weekend are you gonna do anything
about that do those lives not matter do
the innocent people that are getting
shot like you said caught in the
crossfire do they not matter and the
trick that they try and pull is why are
you saying all black people are violent
no no we just showed you three people
and depending on the reports 16 to 20
something people shot that's a very
small percentage in other words if you
look in chicago this is why mass
shootings i think they change it from
three or more to four or more right are
often being perpetrated by a very small
group of people and they're doing it
very often not most black people but
it's the huge percentage of black people
are affected by the way this destroys
their neighborhoods we are not saying
that most black people shoot what we are
saying is most crime violent crime is
perpetrated by a very small percentage
of black people
who by but for some reason because
you're just talking about votes you
don't want to acknowledge i don't want
black people to have to live in fear i
don't want asian salon owners to have to
live in fear and i don't want the white
woman walking through a black
neighborhood to have to live in fear is
that even handed
well it's because they selectively
choose what race they want to tell you
so that's the problem so we have to
bring up the other side of it and by
ignoring it it just causes more death
you're not helping kids not join gangs
you're not helping a better education
you're not teaching firearm safety all
you're doing is sending more kids to the
streets more people to turn into this
and it's it's horrific yeah well they do
have firearm safety courses that's how
they you know teach you to aim it
sideways well that's true
it's called look cool class look
first three rules of firearm safety
finger always on that trigger [ __ ]
sideways and aim
recklessly while running away yes
[Laughter]
shoot kane while he covers up the kid in
the big wheel there you go
we will now move on to concealed carry
no need for a holster just put it in
there now oh man
you might lose your penis yeah
don't worry cheddar bob blues
it's the risk you're willing to take
this is the life the only way out is in
a box
oh boy that's a there's a weird shooting
class i don't like this class at all
this is also a funeral home yeah yeah by
the way uh we need to place another
order for more embalming fluid
so let's get to this the great
replacement theory this is the talk
everywhere and everyone is afraid the
left has been very effective in making
people afraid to even address it now let
me be really clear here
i am not saying
that the great replacement theory is a
theory that needs to be espoused what i
am saying is that there has been a
misrepresentation of course of shooters
how they've been influenced and who is
out there right preaching this idea of
the great replacement theory what they
want to do now people at cnn msnbc abc
nbc cbs you know all of media youtube
twitter facebook they want you to
believe that it is mainstream
republicanism to tout a neo-nazi slogan
of great replacement theory in order
to silence you from discussing a very
real issue of
i wouldn't even necessarily say race i
wouldn't even necessarily do the cop-out
and just say culture but voting
demographics and the purchasing they're
in so uh in case you haven't heard let's
just go here so you see what i'm talking
about uh everyone uh from the left has
been we have a montage right them
blaming buffalo on the great replacement
theory and racist conservatives you
officials believe the gunman accused of
the mass shooting in buffalo was
inspired by the white replacement
conspiracy theory now this is a baseless
belief that white people are being
slowly but intentionally replaced by
minorities and immigrants the concept
was once a fringe theory but now it's
embraced by many republican lawmakers
and fox hosts for example fox news host
tucker carlson
people count up this kind of stuff so
whether you watch him or not the fact is
that the people who do and who track
this note that he has made a reference
or variation to this type of hateful
conspiracy theory this replacement thing
over 400 times since 2016. we also have
you know prominent talking heads tucker
carlson fox news making hundreds of
references a study has shown hundreds of
references to this kind of great
replacement theory you peer review that
white genocide so when people like
tucker carlson
present a ready for cable version of the
theory
it makes more extreme versions of it
more accessible to audiences who would
have never encountered it or would have
never really thought about it i hate
that through the media
and politics the internet
has radicalized angry alienated lost and
isolated individuals into falsely
believing
that they will be replaced that's the
word replaced
okay so let me be clear about something
they're trying to use the term the great
replacement theory and the reason for
that is that's basically an anti-semitic
sort of fringe theory that comes from
people who believe that there's this
cabal of jews who are trying to replace
white people okay
of course i don't believe that and this
is very important for me i would like to
see a comment below because i would like
people to see the biggest
you know right leaning youtube channel
that's ever existed uh if you agree with
the sentiment i'm about to express i
don't think that george soros is sitting
there you know killing uh white babies
okay
but what is happening
is demographic changes due to large
amounts of illegal immigration occurring
unchecked and
being made the beneficiaries of the
social safety net a current welfare
system in this country in order to
ensure their votes not saying there's a
planned orchestration of genocide
against white people but there
absolutely
is a plan
in place that is taking place right now
before your very eyes uh in allowing
mass illegal immigration into this
country in order to try and change
voting demographics
now i know you're going to say i want
you to come in if you agree that that's
what's happening and i
didn't have to mention race once by the
way let's be really clear however that
exact sentiment has been expressed for
years by the left and they do make it a
race thing they call it the browning of
america and they brag about it in a few
years we're going to be a majority brown
country white people will not be the
majority in the country anymore this
will be the first generation ever in
american history
in which whites will be a minority of
the generation at some point as of 2007
every year babies being born in this
country whites now with a minority in
2044
everyone is going to be a minority as
the demographics change as white people
become the minority in the country which
is coming demographics is destiny
demographics is destiny demographics is
destiny right the country is changing
i've been saying it here other people
been saying it here for years now even
before donald trump the demographics
is destiny the white population is
declining for the first time in history
in america while the number of
multi-racial americans
have more than doubled so we live in a
country where the demographics are
changing it's becoming less white
correct okay you'll be announcing that
we're calling the 38 electoral votes of
texas for the democratic nominee for
president it's changing it's going to
become a purple state and then a blue
state vampire because of the
demographics because of the population
growth the growth in texas has been
almost entirely driven by non-white
population growth mostly by hispanics
and latino
demographics are destiny so look i think
now it's fair hey there's a huge
difference between believing in the
security uh superiority of one's race
versus acknowledging the changing of
demographics we have an overlay here we
have a reference let's go to overlay j
really quickly there you go those are
the numbers those are the projections
okay and the left is bragging about it
now
i'm going to get to
the history a little bit of immigration
how this changed dramatically
and why there's a difference when people
say well we're a country of immigrants
well that's true
immigration up through the 1960s
certainly the 30s 40s not at all the
same as today here's here's the primary
difference you cannot have open borders
and you cannot have mass immigration
when you have a social safety net and a
welfare culture it's very very different
yeah and that's where we are right now
when that happens you've got to close
the books or at least have a guest book
there's a huge difference between legal
and illegal immigration the left tries
to act as though we throw it all
together look if you look at the irish
the italians the jews these people in
europe who are fleeing wars people will
now say oh what happened to you know
statue of liberty give us you're tired
you're hungry you're poor yeah at that
point in time there was no promise to
feed the hungry no promise to pay the
poor from the taxpayer that's a very
different time it was a very different
reason for people migrating to this
country and it is not a scenario today
that is tenable when you have people
coming in and suckling uh at the public
teat well yeah and they looked at it as
the land of opportunity yes the the way
that they could go and work hard and
make something for themselves not a
place to come and just get taken care of
yes that was the thing it's a little bit
different mentality well what happened
is they were they were they were fleeing
and pending war yeah right
throughout obviously
i don't know if you're a history buff
but yeah do you know the early 20th
century no there were there were two
yeah yeah unfortunately they sort of
they they uh they they blew their wad
when they called the first one like the
great war they had no idea what was
coming oh no the greater like this is
the even this is the best war oh that
doesn't ring right wait so you see three
that's coming any minute so a lot of
people were fleeing europe right because
because of these impending wars they
were constantly under the threat of
tyranny they wanted to be a part of
america they weren't coming here to get
handouts they were not coming here to
this country to break the law not saying
that everyone right now who's coming to
this country is breaking law but a
disproportionate amount of crime
certainly committed on the southern
border is by people who are here
illegally so they came here to they came
here with no promises on boats
few bucks in their pocket
today half of all immigrant households
receive at least one major welfare
program wow
and the left wants mass illegal
immigration why so they can guarantee a
path to citizenship and they can get
votes
race has nothing to do with it
but here's the thing
at one point race did have something to
do with immigration policy and i was
going by wrote this morning or last
night when i was talking about this i
think a lot of you don't know that there
is a proactive shift in immigration
policy you can thank ted kennedy here in
this country because they wanted to
favor big corporations
and keep a permanent working class
okay so let me kind of give you a little
bit of a briefer so uh after world war
ii
there are a lot of immigrants right that
were coming from from uh europe and they
were skilled they were looking for good
jobs in other words they weren't coming
from countries that had not developed
places what do you mean honduras el
salvador mexico places that have not
given anything else and i mean this
anything else to the modern
industrialized world they were coming
from places like germany like poland uh
like parts of the uk well and very
relatively similar cultures too right
right relatively similar culture but
relatively similar and they were looking
for good jobs now here's the thing a lot
of ceos didn't like that because you're
talking about bring immigrants coming in
who are skilled yeah and so they'll want
to be
paid more yeah right so there was a bill
ted kennedy uh supported this bill that
cut off immigration from what you know
we now know as the eu open it up wide to
uh the pacific rim countries okay it's
called the heart seller uh heart seller
immigration act of 1965.
and they claim to expand civil rights uh
you know as far as movement to
immigration and abolishing this national
origins quota system really what it did
is it actually made it nearly impossible
for european immigrants to come here uh
with more skills with more education
because they believed and you know why
why why why favor people from the
pacific rim because you're talking about
people who would come from manufacturing
jobs where they were making pennies go
to the united states and guess what they
were less likely to act for ask for more
and so this was the government saying
hey ceos they want cheap labor and right
now that's not necessary the irish are
coming in and opening up pubs the
italians are coming in and you know
they're opening up restaurants and also
organized crime but i digress they said
hey the germans are coming in and
they're becoming engineers we these ceos
don't want that so let's change our
immigration policy to make sure that we
bring in as unskilled dependent and
therefore grateful to the government
immigrants that we can that was a
decision that was made you need to
understand when you go yeah hold on a
lot of you inherently think there's a
difference you go well if i look at the
irish in italian sure we were a country
of immigrants but it feels like there
was something different yep yeah exactly
this is basically like us today saying
hey china doesn't pay those kids that
work in those factories very much can we
get in on that action can we make it
easier for them to come over here and
just do that here yeah so what you're
saying is like okay let's say america is
uh a buick yes and uh ted kennedy for
example would be a ceo yes okay let's
say
and let's say it's driven into the water
yes now the water is immigration
and it's filling the car and
americans are married joe that's exactly
okay so now mary jo is just getting
surrounded yes but but and the
democratic party waits a day and a half
to alert the authorities correct well
but here's what the the democracy really
is
allegorical that's actually what that's
what happened yeah don't don't worry i'm
going for help so the ceos are just
showing up all wet to a party and going
uh i was here the whole time yeah yeah
oh hey you're all wet behind the ear
good one
good one where's mary yeah i killed the
[ __ ]
by the way that's pretty good oh that
old chatterbox just just so you know
because i know you watching right now
you may be 20 years old 18 years old we
have more people in that demographic
than any other uh you may not know ted
kennedy killed abroad
yes
i mean
that he killed it it actually happened
yes and then left her
and lied about it and didn't even call
for help and she could have been saved
so just just just in case you're
wondering what's this reference it's not
like some esoteric dennis miller it's no
something that everybody no consequences
sorry the last thing there the guy that
punched the guy got more consequences
for that than that kid he got for
killing somebody well it's why the
brother the brothers got assassinated
and they looked at ted and we're like
all right i think he'll be taken out
fine yeah it's like you're not doing
anything right yeah like well we're only
killing all the kennedys who did sleep
with marilyn monroe yeah
that was the list there's nothing i can
do no terrible so jail but you were
going to talk this is also now this
comes to today and all the references
are available at with credit.com there
was a proactive approach in the in in
america's legislative policy to
basically say we don't want to bring in
people who are uh coming from
universities coming from skill we want
to bring in people from sweatshops
because that's what's best for the ceos
yeah and so you know this this bolsters
their voting base like that's what
tucker carlson was talking about when
cnn ran like hit pieces on tucker
carlson right after this shooting they
ran him talking about illegal
immigration people coming in from the
southern border and they're like okay
well how many nearly 1.5 million
encounters thus far in fiscal 2022 i
think it starts in october so it's about
halfway through the year just a little
bit over yeah and compare that to
646 000 encounters for all of fiscal
2020
and that's 800 no it's just it's 646 646
000 that's encounters that's like almost
it's like almost three times well but
not exactly in 2020 donald trump's last
year that was the number right and
they're not even done yet the 1.5
million will likely be 2.5 to 3 million
somewhere in that neighborhood by the
time that fiscal year ends so the next
thing is
they actually the biden administration
so far in this fiscal year which is
about six months old at the time that
they gave the stat has released over 836
000 illegal immigrants into the united
states the catch and release that is
more than the trump administration
encountered by the way how many of them
are getting formula
we don't have those numbers but a lot
yeah quite a bit that's part of it but
shut your mouth do you think this is
your country what are you a racist but
wait a second wait a second i just want
to buy formula
you're giving it to people who aren't
even citizens shut your racist mouth
yeah well the supreme court actually
just heard a case where they basically
wanted to get rid of the stay in mexico
policy where donald trump said look if
you're coming to this country illegally
the door is revolving it goes right back
into mexico and you stay there you can
make your asylum claim there you can get
everything sorted out there this
administration changed that they tried
to change it by executive order and it
got challenged right right so that that
case has been heard hopefully we'll get
a ruling on that this summer but they
are absolutely for oh you're here in the
united states illegally okay we'll set a
court date for you go have fun right and
that's why greg abbott sent busloads up
to washington dc and said look you're
releasing them at our border how about i
bring them to your doorstep i'm not
saying these are bad people i'm just
saying they're not doing it the right
way yeah right so that was the point
they had and they obviously they don't
want a wall they wanted to end title 42
which basically was the coveted
restrictions no voter id
because that's racist even though 87 of
black americans want some kind of id but
at that point black americans are
inconvenient so shut your racist mouth
hey black americans you think you should
have voter id what are you racist well i
just i need id yeah but guess what
they're actually hedging their bets
because they think voter id is racist
and they say you shouldn't have to have
it to vote in this country but they're
also saying that everyone should get an
id just in case justin i wonder why
they're saying because certain states
are having id laws that's why
interesting and so they need to make
they need to ensure that they can get
votes against blue states who knows
mostly arizona nevada georgia
pennsylvania i can't think michigan
maybe something like that
and let me let me end this look it's
about
voting demographics uh just to be clear
i don't believe that that
people use interchangeably that race is
destiny now i also by the way let me be
this is something people won't like to
hear i also don't think there's anything
wrong
with white americans
wanting their neighborhood to look
similar to how it looked with their dad
and their grandparents and you know
people tend to be comfortable around
people they were raised with
have you been to
mexican neighborhoods
in largely black neighborhoods this is
something this is a natural process that
takes place doesn't mean that you should
seclude yourself but i don't blame black
people for watching black entertainment
television i don't blame latino people
for watching telemundo i understand that
we have different tastes because we have
different
cultures melanin doesn't determine how
you vote unfortunately it's about buying
votes from the democratic party like you
so they realized they weren't going to
be able to buy the votes of for example
italian americans who came here and
started businesses and were paying taxes
they realized this back then so they
said let's bring in a bunch of people
who are basically indentured servants
from these countries so they'll be
grateful to us and they'll
they'll vote for us well now you see
that changing a little bit right with
those same asian americans back then
you're no longer convenient for them
you're starting to lean a little more
right so let's now bring in more people
from mexico let's make sure that our
policy favors people coming from these
countries that they hey look you
remember who helped you right you
remember who brought you in you remember
who even during a pandemic we uh we
paused uh the the four is it title 42 we
paused title for you right we remember
we gave you formula remember how to vote
because on the issues they can't when
you look at the issues of
abortion you look at the issues of even
taxes you look at the issues of what's
taking place in schools
brown americans meaning all latino
americans and even muslim americans
including among brown americans and
black americans overwhelmingly would
align with a center-right point of view
so they try to make it about things that
they give you so they can purchase your
vote and then as we see today
they only use you when it's convenient
so look it's not i want to be really
clear about this
it's not about race but it's also it's
not just about culture because people
say it's not just race it's culture
there's a part of that for sure we all
have different cultures but let me let
me let me present something to you okay
to white this is something with white
supremacists that also that really
bothers me uh
to the actual white supremacists and
there are very few like to the four of
you look the boots yeah there are 50
of white people
actually probably more uh in in our
country who share your same culture and
they vote democrat
and by the way right now think about it
and i understand demographics will
change and so you're concerned about
that however
let's assume those demographics the
demographics are already bad enough when
you take people from your own race and
from your own culture
you can't say that it was black people
you can't say that was brown people
who screwed you with barack obama it was
white people with bill clinton with
jimmy carter
so just want to make sure people people
are going to come and say oh it's a cop
out i'm not saying
that there aren't differences inherently
between races i'm not saying there
aren't differences culturally that often
have to do with how people are
that are that are racially based i'm not
saying any of that but what i am saying
is the primary issue is not that and
that's not how the democrats are
thinking of it they're thinking of whose
votes can we buy
and
why don't you talk about half of this
country whose votes have been bought i
would take 10 brown people who look and
act differently from me
for every white person who shares my
race and culture and is voting to take
my rights away
i'd rather have 10 latino american
assuming by the way let's be clear
all legal immigrants
versus one swedish immigrant who comes
in and wants a social safety net system
and by the way now has lost his bragging
rights of being neutral as his shitty
country tries to join nato how about
this once you pay up the back bill
pay your tab and you can get in the
problem is that we have right now a
system of immigration laws with star and
it starts these people and by these
people right now i mean yeah primarily
brown people i mean yeah primarily
people coming from south america by
design just because geographically it's
easiest for them to come in illegally
and it's in the democratic party's best
interest for the immigrants to be
illegal think about that for a second
that by itself
it's in the best interest
of the republican party and of the con
and of the american people
for immigrants to be coming here legally
it is absolutely unequivocally in the
best interest of the democratic party
for them to enter illegally
that's why their policy reflects it
what does that tell you
they want to bring in people
at an intentional deficit
and then promise them a fix
at the cost of your tax dollars so when
people try to bring up the great
replacement theory and blame you
for a mass shooting
hopefully this helps you because you
don't need to be afraid to address the
real issue of demographics the left has
been bragging about it for years all
right and by the way speaking of this
and speaking with of what's affecting
you in taxes i think we actually have
him back now he didn't blow up thomas uh
he's our on-the-ground reporter went has
gone to another gas station uh it's time
to go on the ground with thomas finnegan
[Music]
all right mr finnegan
what's
just do it just that it
i do not like that sound
to continue where i was saying
we're in a more uh impoverished
neighborhood however it looks like the
price of gas is the same it's 439 a
gallon yes
so what i was thinking is what we didn't
take into consideration
is that
uh the gas comes from fossil fuels which
is where we get the oil yeah it's in the
ocean and like the tides sometimes it's
high and sometimes it's low
i don't understand
[Music]
and i think that takes it
that that kind of sounds strange if you
think of everything it doesn't prove any
point
but
would it be all right if i use the
company card to uh
to get some gas i sleep to a friend you
work at the bank yeah no you don't have
a company car we have an issue do you
want and you've made no point [ __ ]
okay i'll uh
get started
how much it work
all right
i think that's enough
[Music]
all right it is my favorite day of the
week chat thursday here for my club
members but after today's show let it
never be said that we here did not take
a risk share if you can that's what the
youtube algorithm favors and uh comment
your thoughts below
i uh i've talked with a lot of people
about this and uh you know what there
are far more of you out there than you
think and the left side do you mean
racist no no i mean anti-racists you
racist sons of [ __ ] and just [ __ ]
so youtube piss off
you